a reigning champion of the IndyCar
Series up for driver of the year yes
tonight in the ESPYs good to see you
Scott thanks thanks having me you bet
thank you do you have your suit all
picked out what's uh what's going down
tonight Scott I was just gonna wear
shorts tonight I think Beach's higher is
that would be great I should be good
right especially with my nice white
ginger skin you know I think it's gonna
look good I mean it's something I'm
gonna be pink I think I think the white
ginger skin short ESPYs look is
something that's a rarity I go for it I
think it will get some attention for
sure do maybe just underwear okay you
know what just another tiny whining
ginger white skinny ESPN experience it
reminds me of my 1997 espn2 ahh I think
everybody needs to see that everybody
does everybody but so this is your sixth
espy nomination yeah it's been a lot but
zero wins I feel lucky to be nominated
you know I think it's very nice yes it
is an R it is what I mean that means
you've to be nominated miss many times
it means you've won which is great I
know you know it's like coming second a
lot of the time you definitely want to
get that top spot but it's a tough crowd
it's always a tough crowd
you know the ESPYs is always a huge
event and one that I've been to a few
times before but yeah I think with Lewis
Hamilton Ocean and Bush and Steve
Torrance yes Steve times you can't lose
to a drag racer though Scott let's be
honest I mean number one is the only one
that counts for you don't and you know I
don't mean to put you in a difficult
position but I might just I mean in all
honesty what what driving is there what
I mean you want to talk about driving
when you're there it has to be obviously
some steering when you come to drag
racing but compared to what you do I
mean you can't you can't compare these
things that'd be like following they'll
be like me when I'm up against somebody
who hosts a show that's like three
minutes long I do three hours a day yeah
if we get nominated for the same
category I'd be like I'm honored to be
nominated with this person probably like
this just come on it's not the same
thing yeah I think everything has its
purpose and difficulties right which
drag racing you know I know although the
drag races and
and it is tough you know it is tough
it's a lot of power of never driven one
actually so I can't really comment I
know you've never done we in 2003 and
nearly did a swap with Larry Dixon we
both won the chairmanship the same year
and relation no no relation and actually
I think chip at the time put it we
things didn't meet up and we weren't
able to do it but I'd love to drive one
of those things well the 8,000 10,000
horsepower of something crazy so a
little more than than the Indy cow but
yeah you're just driving straight just
driving straight you don't have to make
any turns and I think you gotta correct
a little bit there's no there's no light
again and I don't are we dragging on
drag racing right now Chris is that the
problem right now but yeah horses short
track ovals recourses IndyCar I think is
is the most diverse series in the world
so I love the the difference between the
categories or sorry not categories but
right okay so we get to go to Scott
Dixon here he's up for best driver of
the Year award tonight at the ESPYs and
a fellow a honda individual right here
all right you can still vote today can
you still vote today I believe I believe
Chris can we click on on Scott Dixon on
it let's do that and then let's give
them our vote right here for sure of
course no doubt about it
and who was giving out the order tonight
who's giving you do you know who's
presenting that I don't actually I think
they typically only do the presentation
maybe to five or ten of the categories
this won't be live presented tonight
this is like an other receiving votes or
try to see it go across the screen have
a speech prepared for no speech I don't
think you're allowed to do speeches man
I know I thought about that one you know
after being nominated six times and zero
wins you know I thought it was it was at
least gonna get two or three minutes as
GOG Dixon if you're showing up tonight
in shorts and you wear your storm in
that stage I'm getting up there you get
up there and just say you know just get
out of the way you know obviously uh you
know prayer need to come up with
something
the host will be probably standing right
there Tracy Morgan Tracy Morgan will be
right there Jim maybe Tracy is gonna
announce that if it's just it's gonna be
hey here's the winner yeah maybe I can
help him didn't he just crash his be
getting something buying it yeah like
driving an awful lot it's two million
dollar car yeah huh
I think somebody ran into him maybe
probably what you're Scott Dixon here in
the Richard show what is the most ornate
car you've ever driven well I love my
Acura MDX obviously it sure it's a
fantastic car let's check that box the
history of your life
no I didn't realize I was I might have
been stepping into a sponsorship but I
don't know like it's hard once you drive
a proper car right lane I've driven
Formula One I've driven an IndyCar and
and those and once you get to the RO but
I don't know I've been part of the the
Ford GT program with the new car that
just came out I'm 16 I mean just driving
as a human being on the planet like
going to the store if you ever heard
somebody you know a friend of yours had
some an insane car and you're just like
I just got behind the wheel and drive it
no the Saint was quite found the new
McLaren Senna
I drove a 1906 dirac there was there was
like a tractor man but it I think was a
16 litre engine I had like three speeds
give you what is it like driving in
something built in 1906 it was crazy
scary actually scary so you're sitting
very high almost an attractor the whole
thing is basically just an engine it's
got very skinny tires and I had to I
drove it in New Zealand and the Leadfoot
festival which is a hillclimb race okay
but it had a ton of torque power it's
but the hardest thing was was they you
know naturally you want to brake with
your foot but it had a handbrake so you
changing gears and you got this big
lever thing that clicks down and you got
a big hand brake and then when you want
to let it off you got to pull it back
and away you go but it was crazy but you
got a bigger wheel it was it was fun did
you reflexively reach for a seatbelt
sliding across the beam see you know
like it it was definitely an interesting
thing so I wouldn't say that that was
the the most ornate thing sure that
sound now that that happens I mean you
gotta drive what do you like being
driven Scott Dixon what do you like when
you are not in the crash I'm pretty
quiet you know as long as it's not my
wife my wife is can be pretty dangerous
on the road alright let's get into this
a little bit what do you mean well you
know she is an amazing person but has a
very small attention span which i think
is very bad poor for driving on the
roads okay so you know she'll notice a
bird that's flying by or a squirrel you
know she'll she'll crash a road car just
to miss a squirrel you know right off a
cliff public yeah you know it all comes
out every life is important yes don't go
metal right as long as our kids down on
the car your kids probably just too
antenna she on the fifth of July thirty
seven so yeah there are two little girls
and seven yeah okay do they have any do
they have any interest in driving
competitively you think they hadn't
really Tilly our youngest is is into
horses but poppy has been asking a lot
lately so I've taken her indoor go
counting a couple of times and and she's
thoroughly enjoyed it now what was
dangerous horses you might have found
the one part of the I guess sporting
world that's more expensive than driving
race cars like you I would think we're
just dipping our toes you know we're
just stepping out eyes we have lots of
plastic what's the what's there's a
brand the starts with this or something
that you know the toys okay she has
probably every model that's ever been
okay selected and let me just give you a
little bit of advice if you could stick
to that that'd be a good thing yes yeah
yeah we have one horse and it's actually
it's my wife's horse okay she bought her
is a retired racehorse okay and was
meant to do you know things on it and
and then it got injured and and now we
just have like another large pet dog
that is quite expensive you know to
board and feed and and
this thing I think is gonna live forever
- you know it's not that pricey Scott
Dixon here on the Rich Eisen show do you
go from here to Toronto
are you going straight to Toronto
tonight yeah yeah okay so you are you
ready ESPYs you're gonna get that you're
gonna get the award
you're gonna storm the stage you're
gonna shove Tracy Morgan out of the way
grab the microphone you're gonna thank
your wife and her short attention span
children and your whole Honda you'll
think about ganassi racing you would
love weed off your shirt and then you're
you're going straight to Toronto Toronto
yeah we Sabbath media day on on Thursday
with defending race champions there so
hopefully a good fourth place right now
for the oval for the championship yeah
we've had a bit of a rough year we
definitely made some gains kind of after
the 500 we got caught up in a crash
there and you know the 500 it's double
points so it's very easy to lose
traction in the championship but we
fought back strong got the win in
Detroit and then we got caught up in
accident Texas and you know had problems
in Road America so yeah I think we've
shown a lot more speed than than where
we're sitting right now but it's time to
it's it's make-or-break right now we're
gonna start winning some I'm sure but
you are going to a spot where you have
won before I mean what is that like
where you go to a spot do you feel more
comfortable behind I mean it's the it's
the cards the wheel it's that it's a
track but just the fact that it's in a
spot where you've won before is there is
there a mental aspect of this thing I
think you know in every sport all kind
of in in any any line you know I think
when you go in with a lot more
confidence into a place that you know as
being a proven winner I think for us and
for our team we've we've won there a lot
so it helps but you can't you can't
dwell on that or rest on that you know
we with any sport or any series - it
keeps pushing forward and the
competition right now is it's just
through the roof so it's definitely not
gonna be easy but yeah it's great to go
back to Toronto and you know the first
goal is to go back and try and defend
last year's one well I hope you have a
nice carry on item for tonight's flying
yeah that'd be cool right you've carried
on my tighty-whities only rockin man
are you rockin well I would suggest you
mom I get removed put something on
before you complain I mean do what you
wish for the ESPYs before get in a play
in an international flight that's for
sure
doing the reverse Kawhi Leonard going
from Los Angeles to Toronto Scott Dixon
good luck tonight sir and good luck
throughout the rest of the way very much
appreciated Rogers in Honda right here
on the Rich Eisen show Scott Dixon at
Scott Dixon 9 on both Twitter and
Instagram right here on the Rich Eisen
ship for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app